Mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Doktor.
Ok. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Ok?
Ok.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Maria Kaiser.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam bestabeln?
M-A-R-I-A. Maria.
Ja.
A-I-S-E-R. Kaiser.
K-A oder E wie E mit?
A-A-I-S-I-R.
Ok. Frau Kaiser, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
23.9.1968
Ok. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
65 Kilogramm.
Danke für die Informationen, Frau Kaiser. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ich habe starke Husten Doktor.
Seit wann leiden Sie hinter Husten?
Seit zwei Monaten habe ich diese Beschwerden.
Frau Kaiser, sind diese Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Diese Beschwerden plötzlich, hat plötzlich aufgetreten Doktor.
Und haben sich die Beschwerden mit der Zeit verändert? Ich meine schlimmer geworden, besser geworden?
Ja, die Beschwerden sind in der Verlaufszeit immer schlimmer geworden. Aber meine Beschwerden sind immer dauerhaft. Nicht gehen wieder weg Doktor.
Ok. Also treten Sie die Husten tagsüber auch in der Nacht?
Besonders am Abend, aber tagsüber habe ich sie.
Frau Kaiser, ist die Husten trocken oder mit dem Auswurf?
Ich meine, dass die Husten mit dem Auswurf, ja Doktor.
Und wie sah der Auswurf aus? Ich meine schleimig, grünlich, gelblich?
Ja, der Auswurf ist braunisch.
Außerdem habe ich gestern Blutfaden im Auswurf bemerkt Doktor.
Ok, das war meine nächste Frage. Danke für diese Information Frau Kaiser.
Ok, nur einmal haben Sie Blut im Auswurf bemerkt, richtig?
Ja, gestern habe ich bemerkt. Früher habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ok. Frau Kaiser, leiden Sie unter Luftnot?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben Recht. Seit Kurzem bekomme ich bei Treppen steigen schlechte Luft.
Ich merke, dass mir die Husten ausgeht.
Ich will nicht Luft bekommen. Verstehen Sie?
Ja, meine Internetverbindung ist schlecht, aber ich denke, ich habe richtig verstanden.
Frau Kaiser, steht die Luftnot nur bei Belastung oder auch in Ruhe?
Bei Belastung, nicht in Ruhe Doktor.
Ok, wie viele Treppen können Sie aussteigen ohne Luftnot zu bekommen?
Ja Doktor, ich wohne im ersten Stück. Wenn ich in mein Haus gehe, muss ich mindestens zweimal Pause machen.
Ok, und Frau Kaiser, leiden Sie unter Luftnot auch in der Nacht?
Nein, besonders beim Laufen oder Steigen.
Ok, fällt Ihnen das Atmen schwer, wenn Sie flach liegen?
Ja Doktor, Sie haben Recht.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ich benutze zwei Kissen.
Ok, Frau Kaiser, fühlen Sie sich müde generell?
Ja Doktor, ich fühle mich sehr müde. Ich bin total erschrocken.
Aber seit ein Wochen, vor zwei Wochen, fühle ich mich gut.
Haben Sie viel Ball, Frau Kaiser?
Ich habe nicht gegessen, aber ich fühle mich ein bisschen fibrisch.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Ich habe nicht bemüht.
Ok, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja Doktor, ich habe kaum Appetit. Seit einem Monat habe ich keinen Appetit.
Ok, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirkürlich abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe nicht genau, wie viel, aber mehrere Leute aus meinem Umfeld haben mir da angesprochen, dass ich abgenommen habe.
Leiden Sie unter Schmerzen, wenn Sie besonders tief einatmen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Ok, Frau Kaiser, haben Sie geschworene Lymphknoten besonders in der Achselhöhle oder im Leichtenbereich bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht untersucht, aber ich denke, habe ich nicht diese Beschwerden, Doktor.
Ok, das freut mich. Leiden Sie unter Sodbrennen oder Sauerausgestoßen?
Ich habe keine diese Beschwerden, Doktor.
Ok, und ich würde fragen, ob Sie eine Brustschmerzen oder Herzrasen haben, Frau Kaiser?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Ok, super.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe gesagt, ich benutze zwei Kissen und deswegen diese Probleme. Und außerdem habe ich viel Angst über Krebs. Ja, ich schlafe nicht gut, Doktor.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Weiter.
Ok, Frau Kaiser, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Angst vor Krebs haben.
Also, ich möchte Sie beruhigen. Es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen, aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Ihre Beschwerden können viele verschiedene Ursachen haben.
Ok.
Wissen Sie Doktor, mein Vater ist an Brutkrebs gestorben, mit 66 Jahren alt. Ich habe viel Angst über Krebs.
Haben Sie Brutkrebs gesagt oder Brust?
Brustkrebs, ja.
Ihr Vater oder Ihre Mutter?
Mein Vater.
Ok. Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Frau Kaiser. Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Ich empfehle Ihnen positiv zu denken, da der Krebs nicht 100% erblich ist. Ja?
Ja.
Ok.
Das hat mir richtig Angst gemacht. Deswegen habe ich sofort einen Termin bei Ihnen ausgemacht, Doktor. Danke schön.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Ok. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe keine Probleme.
Ok. Frau Kaiser, sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig gegen die Kronik, Doktor. So wie viermal gegen Covid-19.
Ok. Frau Kaiser, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe Krampfada in beiden Beinen seit drei Jahren.
Und Frau Kaiser, leiden Sie unter geschwollene Beinen?
Ein bisschen, aber besonders nachts.
Geschwollene Beine, meinen Sie?
Ja, beide Beine, aber nicht viele. Manchmal, ja.
Ok. Und nehmen Sie ein Medikament gegen Krampfada ein oder benutzen Sie eine Strümpfe vielleicht?
Ja, ich benutze eine Strümpfe, Doktor. Ich nehme keine Medikamente gegen diese Beschwerden ein.
Alles klar. Sonst noch etwas?
Das war.
Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe keine anderen Erkrankungen.
Ok. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme ...
Mit Kopfschmerzen oder Rückenschmerzen, naja?
Ja, ich nehme zurzeit Hüstersaft, das ihr Frau von der Apotheke gebt habt. Und gelegentlich Schlafmittel benutzen.
Aber ich habe diese Schlafmittel von EDKG, Doktor.
Ist das richtig für mich?
Frau Kaiser, also die Einnahme von Medikamenten ohne Ärztekinderheit kann für Sie gefährlich sein.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, Ihre Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin regelmäßig zu besuchen für Ihre Beschwerden, ja?
Ok, danke schön.
Gerne. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, vor acht Jahren wurde mir ein Kalemblase entfernt.
Sonst noch etwas?
Das war Doktor.
Ok. Ist diese Operation verlaufen oder komplikationslos?
Ja, ja. Es war komplikationslos.
Super.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ich reagiere allergisch auf Ayadoktor.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das äußert sich mit Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen.
Ok. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider Doktor. Ich rauche seit meinem 18. Lebenjahr täglich eine Packung Zigaretten.
Ok.
Frau Kaiser, wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen.
Wir haben ein gutes Programm im Krankenhaus mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören oder mindestens das Rauchen zu reduzieren. Ok?
Ja Doktor. Ich wäre Ihnen dankbar, wenn ich mir helfen könnte, weil ich viele Mal gesagt habe, aber ich habe nicht geschafft.
Ja, sehr gerne. Wir können darüber nach dem Anamnesigespräch widersprechen. Ok?
Danke schön Doktor.
Gerne. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich nur als Erdnuss.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ein Verein oder Treffen mit meinen Freunden oder Freunden.
Oder am Wochenende.
Ein Gleis Wein.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe nicht mit Drogen konsumiert.
Das freut mich. Sehr gut.
Frau Kaiser, Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihr Vater vor 6 Jahren an Brustkrebs verstorben ist.
66 Jahre.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Mit 66 Jahren. Das tut mir leid, das zu hören.
Und wie ist Ihre Mutter? Ist sie gesund?
Meine Mutter ist gesund, aber sie hat ein Alzeimer. Sie lebt jetzt in Altenheim.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Nein, sie hat Downsindrome.
Es tut mir leid, das zu hören.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder. Sie sind Zivilen.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Gott sei Dank.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich lebe mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Okay, was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Meine Frau, Entschuldigung.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf, Frau Kaiser?
Ich arbeite als Postbote.
Entschuldigung, können Sie das wiederholen?
Postbote.
Sind Sie Briefträger?
Ja, richtig.
Verstanden.
Frau Kaiser, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe gesagt, was habe ich?
Ja, Frau Kaiser, es ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen.
Aber ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit der Atemwege haben.
Die Atemwege oder die Lungen.
Aber ich möchte zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Okay?
Es dauert so lange, Doktor. Ich muss arbeiten.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Frau Kaiser.
Ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Und machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Wir werden Ihnen krank schreiben.
Okay. Wurden bei mir eine operiert oder?
Frau Kaiser, könnte es sein, dass Sie operiert werden müssen.
Aber es ist zu früh, das genau zu sagen.
Wie gesagt, zuerst müssen wir die Diagnose sichern.
Dann können wir über 100% sichere Diagnose und über die Therapiemöglichkeiten widersprechen.
Okay, danke schön, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Frau Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Und ich würde über Sie berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Frau Maria Kaiser ist 54 Jahre alt, 1,70 Meter groß, 65 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Kaiser stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Monaten bestehender Prodiktivatosis mit dem bräunlichen Sputum vor.
Der Patienten zufolge seien die Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Patienten berietete, dass sie gestern eine Hämopäthie beobachtet haben.
Sie erwähnte die Spur beim Bewegung, besonders beim Treppensteigen.
Sie müsse zweimal Pause machen.
Die Patienten, normalerweise wohnen sie in der ersten Strecke.
Außerdem klagte sie über Urtopneu.
Deswegen benutze sie zwei Kissen beim Schlafen.
Sie erwähnte Fatigue und Asthenie seit einer Woche.
Die Fragen nach nächtlicher Hyperhydrose, Sterfrost, Lymphadenopathie, Pirosis, Angina Pectoris und Tachycardie und Beinodeme wurden verneint.
Sie berietete über Gewichtsabnahme.
Gewichtsabnahme sollte geklärt werden.
Sie berietete auch über Fieber.
Sie haben das Fieber nicht gemessen.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen unauffällig.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und viermal COVID-19 geimpft.
Leider habe ich die Frauenanamnese vergessen zu fragen.
Aber nach dem Arztarztgespräch werde ich diese Frage nicht bestellen.
Anfroerkrankungen nannte sie seit drei Jahren bestehende beidseitige Varykose an den Beinen, die mit der Kompression Strumpfe behandelt worden sei.
Sie nehme Hustensaft und Schlafmittel ein.
Die Namen von Medikamenten sollten geklärt werden.
Diese Medikamente habe sie ohne ärztlichen Rat eingenommen.
Vor acht Jahren wurde bei ihr eine Scholarsystektomie durchgeführt.
Sie hatte Allergie gegen Eier, die sich durch Diarrhea und Abdominal Schmerzen äußerte.
Sie war Raucherin und rauchte eine Schachter Zigaretten täglich seit 18 Lebensjahren.
Sie trinke ein Glas Wein am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater an Mama Carcinom mit 66 Jahren verstorben sei.
Die Mutter leide an Alzheimer und wohne in einem alten Heim.
Sie habe eine Schwester, die an Trisomie 21 leidet.
Die Patientin sei geschieden, habe gesunde Zwillinge und wohne mit ihrem Partner zusammen.
Sie sei Briefträger von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Bronchiakarcinom aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter chronischer Husten, Dyspne und Ozebne.
Sie leidet unter Fatigue, Asthenie, Fieber und Gewichtsabnahme.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Bronchiakarcinom.
Als die Phalansealdiagnosen kommen Knoimonie, Herzinsuffizienz in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patientin die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, geschwollene Lymphknoten und mögliche Pathologien bei der Askultation
vorhanden sind.
Zunächst ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose sich zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Herzenzime, Geronuxparameter, Tumormarkers, BNP bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich zwei Ebenen Röntgen des Thorax durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Bronchoscopie durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Zusätzlich würde ich eine CT des Thorax, um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen.
Und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine PCT durchführen, um die Metastase genau zu überprüfen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin Station aufnehmen.
Ich würde einen Venosuzugang legen. Wenn nötig, würde ich eine Antibiotika verabreichen, Antithesis verabreichen.
Und auch würde ich ein Onkologisches und Pneumonologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patientin zu optimieren.
Nach der Behandlung würde ich der Patientin Lebensstilveränderungen empfehlen, wie zum Beispiel Nikotinkarenz, Alkoholkarenz.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Eingehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Vorgehensweise.
Herr Kollegen, denken Sie in diesem Fall über Klos und COPD?
Ich bin unter der Zeit des Durchbluts. Deswegen sollen wir auf jeden Fall diese Diagnose denken.
Aber leider habe ich keine Reiseanamnese gefragt. Nach dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch werde ich über Reiseanamnese fragen.
Ich bin ein Arzt, der seit 18 Jahren in der Klinik gearbeitet hat. Das ist ein Faktor für COPD.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Umgebung eine Beschwerden zu haben?
Ich habe auch keine Frage gestellt. Aber werde ich diese Frage nach dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch stellen?
Ich denke, wenn Sie eine Tuberkulose ausschließen, müssen Sie diese Frage stellen. Warum denken Sie nicht COPD?
COPD kommt als Differenzialdiagnose.
Sie ist eine starke Raucherin.
Aber gibt es auch Hemopetizide, chronische Fatigue und Asthenie?
Diese Symptome sind zum Beispiel für eine Kaktik.
Wie lange dauert es, wenn wir eine COPD-Diagnose stellen?
Seit zwei Monaten leidet sie unter Husten und seit einer Woche unter Dyspnoe.
Diese Zeit ist etwas kurz für eine COPD. Normalerweise warten wir lange Zeit für diese Beschwerden bei einer COPD.
Wir haben sie mindestens drei Monate gebraucht.
Was beachten Sie von der COPD?
Bei der COPD können wir eine mediastinale Verschiebung feststellen, vergrößerte Hilum-Lymphknoten feststellen, Tumore-Schatten feststellen.
Das war's.
Was erwarten Sie von einer Bronchoscopy?
Bei der Bronchoscopy-Untersuchung können wir die Tumore auf der Atemwege feststellen und gleichzeitig eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Was führen Sie eine PEC-Sekundur?
Um die mögliche Metastase festzustellen, können wir eine PCT durchführen, Herr Oberst.
Können Sie uns so eine PCT aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über eine PCT aufklären.
PCT gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Position, Emission, Tomographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Tumore und die Metastase genauso erkennen.
Vor der Untersuchung verabreichen wir dem Patienten eine leichte radioaktives Stoffe.
Wir warten auf ungefähr 80 Minuten für die Verteilung in den ganzen Körper.
Danach machen wir eine CT-Untersuchung.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten in eine CT-Röhre legen.
Wenn der Patient eine Blasangst hat, können wir dem Patienten ein Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung hat keine Komplikationen, aber es gibt einige Kontraindikationen, wie zum Beispiel Schwangerschaft und Kontrastmittelallergie.
Für diese Untersuchung benötigt der Patient etwa sechs Stunden nüchtern sein.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anstrengungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Was hängt die Therapie der Patienten davon ab?
Das Stadium des Tumors ist sehr wichtig.
Bei deslokalisierten Tumors können wir eine Operation durchführen, wie zum Beispiel Lobectomie.
Bei der fortgeschrittenen oder Metastasiatentumor können wir Chemotherapie, Radiotherapie und eine symptomatische Therapie durchführen.
Ich habe den Namen wieder vergessen.
Wie können wir das Stadium des Tumors stellen?
TNM-Klassifikationen können wir benutzen, um das Stadium festzustellen.
T-Tumor, N-Leaf-Node-Metastase und M-Fernmetastase.
Was beachten wir während der Therapie?
Was meinen Sie damit, Herr Oberhaus? Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Als Komplikationen meinen Sie oder?
Das gesamte Verfahren als Medikamentostherapie.
Die Patienten sollen regelmäßig ihre Ärzte besuchen, um eine vollständige Therapie zu erhalten.
Lebensstilveränderung ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten. Sie ist eine starke Raucherin.
Nikotinkarenz ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten.
Empfehlen Sie der Patienten ausreichende Ernährung?
Ja, ausreichende Ernährung ist sehr wichtig für das Immunsystem bei den Patienten.
Regelmäßige Ernährung, gesunde Ernährung ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten.
Wenn die Patienten eine starke Ernährung haben, welche Medikamentostherapie verabreichen Sie?
Das ist eine gute Frage, Herr Oberhaus. Aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher mit einigen Details zu diesem Thema. Ich werde nach der Erpüfung es recherchieren.
Und dann Satran.
Okay.
So ein bisschen ist schon vorhanden, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen. Bitte gehen Sie in unser Infodisk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikate.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihr Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberhaus. Sie sind sehr nett. Das war ein super angenehmes Gespräch bei mir.
Vielen Dank.
Eine neue Patientin. Darf ich Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen?
Ja, bitte.
Frau Kaiser. Es handelt sich um Frau Maria Kaiser. Sie ist 54 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 65 Kilogramm schwer. Sie ist 1,70 Meter groß.
Sie ist heute bei uns, weil sie seit zwei Monaten starke Tussis hat.
Die Patienten sind dadurch, dass die Tussis langsam aufgetreten sind.
Die Patienten verstehen, dass die Tussis mit Blut ausgebildet werden.
Außerdem teilt sie mit den Patienten eine Atemnote.
Sie haben eine Atemnote. Sie haben eine Atemnote.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Insomnie und Apathitlosigkeit wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Die Frage nach Präxie, Herzrasen und Probleme mit Mission und Sturgang würden verneint.
Und bei ihr wurde eine Kalemblaseoperation durchgeführt vor acht Jahren.
Bitte wiederholen ihr die Liste.
Bei ihr wurde vor acht Jahren eine Kalemblase...
...kollessistektomie...
...kollessistektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, richtig.
Danke schön.
Im Basuk der Medikation nehmen sie einen Husten-Saft und ein Schlafmittel ein.
Aber der Wirkstoff und die Häufigkeit sollten geklagt werden.
Medikamente, ja.
Sie rauchen seit sechstenteleven Jahren täglich eine Packung Zigaretten.
Sie trinken gelegenlich Alkohol.
In Besuch auf die Familienanamnese teilt sie mit, dass der Vater mit 66 Jahre alt an Mama Karsinoma gestorben ist.
Die Mutter hat eine Alzheimer-Krankheit und lebt in Altenheim.
Sie hat eine Schwester, die Down-Syndrome hat.
Sie arbeitet als Postpon.
Sie hat eine Schwester, eine Schwesterin.
Sie lebt mit seinen Frauen zusammen.
Ich gehe von Verdacht auf Bronchial Karsinoma aus, da die Patienten typische Symptome dafür ausweisen.
Die Patienten leiden seit zwei Wochen bestehende Thesis und starke Dyspne und Gewichtverlust.
Die Thesis gehen mit gelegenen Schuputum und Hemoptis.
Die Patienten leiden seit zwei Wochen bestehende Thesis und Schuputum und Hemoptis.
Die Diagnose ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Sie ist ein sehr common COPD, Pneumonia, Tuberculosis, Infrage.
Die Patienten leiden seit zwei Wochen bestehende Thesis und Hemoptis.
Dann würde ich den Patienten einen Intervenuszugang legen und würde ich eine Laborkontanz durchführen.
Dann würde ich einen Blutbild, ein Sunduckparameter, eine CRP, eine Lebewerte, ein Nierenwerte, ein Sunduckparameter bestimmen lassen.
Dann würde ich eine Röntgen-Torax durchführen, um mögliche lungen Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Dann würde ich eine Spirometer durchführen, um mögliche lungen Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Dann würde ich eine Stethatore durchführen, um mögliche lungen Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Dann würde ich eine Bronchoskopie durchführen.
Dann würde ich eine Bronchoskopie durchführen, um mögliche Leibwerte durchzuführen.
Dann würde ich eine Antnehmen durchführen.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen würde, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich einen Intervenussugang legen, um Physik, Antibiotika, Analyse und Therapie zu machen.
Dann würde ich eine Pneumologiekonsultation anbieten, um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Ich habe es versucht, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich etwas schrecklich gemacht habe.
Generell ist es sehr gut, es gibt nur kleine grammatische Fehler.